welcome to Simply learn in this video we
will see what is data science need of
data science skills in data science data
preparation for data science so before
we begin consider subscribing to Simply
land and hit the Bell icon to never miss
any updates from us now you must have
already heard about autonomous cars so
I'm sure you must be excited to have a
car driving by itself which will take
you from home to office or office to
home right and that's where one of the
examples where data science is used now
the car needs to take a lot of decisions
in this whole process whether to speed
up whether to apply the break take a
left turn right turn or slow down so all
these decisions are basically a part of
data science and there is a study that
says that self-driving cars will
minimize is accidents and in fact it
will root out more than 2 million deaths
caused by car accidents annually
self-driving cars right now there's a
lot of research and there is a lot of
testing going on and not a lot of cars
are yet in production in terms of usage
but it's going to happen every
automotive company worth its name is
investing in self-driving cars so in
about 10 15 years some of the studies
say that most of the cars will be
autonomous or self-driving cars where
else there are issues for example if we
take Airlines this is another area where
data science contributes in a major way
flights get delayed due to weather
conditions because the weather is not
predicted in time and the demand of
passengers is not probably seen ahead of
time for all the these un need data
signs then this could be improper route
planning and uh some customers might
miss some flights that again needs data
science and similarly it could be
incorrect decisions in selecting the
right equipment so which plane should
fly in which route that's the equipment
that's being mentioned here if that is
not planned properly then you might end
up in a situation where the plane is not
available whereas you have planned for a
flight in a particular routee so these
are some of the challenges in one of the
representative Industries we are talking
about which is Airlines so if we use
data science properly all of these or
most of these problems can be avoided
and that will help in reducing the pain
both for the Airlines and also for the
passengers a few more examples what else
can we do here are some of the other
things that we can do and we will stick
to the A line industry we can do better
route planning so that there are less
cancellations and less frustrated people
we can predict use Predictive Analytics
and predict any delays that are there so
that some flights can be rescheduled
ahead of time and there are no last
minute changes data science can also be
used to make promotional offers and the
last but not least is what kind of
planes should be used on the different
classes of planes that should be used in
different routes for better performance
so these are some examples of how data
science can be used in Airlines and
under example or under industry where
data science can be used and benefited
would be in logistics so companies like
FedEx they use data science models to
increase their efficiency drastically to
optimize the roots and cut costs and so
on so before there delivery truck
actually sets out they determine which
is the best possible route to ship their
items to the customers and based on
various inputs they also predict or come
up with the best suited time to deliver
and last but not least they determine
what is the best mode of Transport for
this delivery as well so what is data
science used for these are some of the
main areas where data science is used
for better decision making there are
always tricky decisions to be made so
which is the right decision which way to
go so that is one area then for
predicting for performing predictive
analysis like for example can we predict
delays like in the case of Airlines can
we predict the demand for certain
products let's say in e-commerce that is
the second area the third area is
pattern Discovery or pattern recognition
is there a pattern in which people are
buying items for example it could be
seasonality if you take the data sales
data for multiple years there may be a
pattern in the way people are buying
that that's a buying pattern certain
months probably the sales will increase
certain months the sales will come down
certain quarters traditionally the sales
will be higher certain quarter so that
is a pattern and this pattern Discovery
is another area where data science is
applied so what is data science now
let's take an example a real life
example on a day-to-day basis we use or
we we try to make some decisions let's
say we want to buy some furniture online
for our new office so how do you go
about doing this you need to take a
bunch of decisions to actually do the
purchase so we start with which website
which portal or which website you should
use so we try to find out let's say you
want to buy the furniture obviously you
don't go to a online grocery store
because you need Furniture because there
are several websites so that is the
first decision you need to take which
website I should use so once we have
multiple websites you kind of discard
all the websites which don't sell
furniture and you stick to those
websites which sell Furniture now within
that we try to find out what is the
ratings of this websites if the ratings
is more that means they are reliable the
quality probably is good and so on and
so forth so only then you want to buy
from that particular website so anything
that doesn't satisfy this criteria you
close all those websites close in the
sense you close the browser right so you
still are left with maybe a few of these
which satisfy your criteria that is
which sell web pages or websites that
sell furniture they have a rating of
four and above and then you look for
Discount is somebody providing discount
greater than 20% then again you filter
out some of them which probably are not
providing any discount and zero down to
one or two websites which are probably
providing those discounts and go ahead
and select the furniture and purchase it
so this a very basic example you
probably don't follow this always
exactly the same way but just to
illustrate drive home the point so we
can answer a lot of questions using data
science for example when we take a cab
when we book a cab now to go from
location a to location B what is the
best route that the cab can take to
reach in the fastest way or in the least
amount of time there could be several
factors there could be traffic there
could be bad Road there could be weather
now all these come as inputs and a
decision needs to be taken as to which
is the best route another example is TV
shows so Netflix and uh maybe even other
a lot of other TV channels they have to
perform this analysis to find out what
kind of shows people are viewing what
kind of shows people are liking and and
so on and so forth so that they can then
sell this information to advertisers
because their main source of Revenue is
advertising so this is again major
function of data science predictive
maintenance we need to find out will my
car break down will my refrigerator
breakdown in the next year or two years
should I be prepared to buy a new
refrigerator you can potentially apply
data science here as well and then in
politics a lot of data science is
applied in politics you must have seen
on TV about us elections or in UK or
even in India nowadays everybody is
applying data science in elections and
trying to capture the votes or rather
the vote vers influence the voters
personalized messages providing
personalized messages and and so on and
so forth and that is one not only that
people use data science to even predict
who is going to win the elections it's a
different matter that probably not all
predictions come out to be true but then
yes this is they use data science to do
this uh predictions so what is the
process or what are the various steps in
in data science the first step is asking
the right question and exploring the
data basically you want to know what
exactly is the problem you're trying to
solve so that is asking the right
question so that is the this circle out
here then the next step is after
exploring the data so as a first step
you will ask some questions what exactly
is the problem you're trying to solve
and then obviously you will have some
data for that as input and you perform
some exploratory analysis on the data
for example you need to clean the data
to make sure everything is fine and so
on and so forth so all that is a part of
exploratory analysis and then you need
to do the modeling let's say if you have
to perform machine learning you need to
decide which algorithm to use and which
model to use and then you need to train
the model and so on and so forth so
that's all part of the modeling process
and then you run your data through this
model and then through this process and
then you come out with the final results
of this exercise which includes
visualizing the results and preparing a
way to communicate the results to the
concerned people so it could be in the
form of PowerPoint slides or it could be
in the form of a a dashboard which is
basically what we call as a
visualization and so all the insights
that have been gathered through through
this exercise that has to be
communicated in a proper way in a easy
to understand way which is again a a key
part of this whole exercise
communicating the results so what are
the prerequisites for data science there
are three essential traits required for
to be a data scientist one is curiosity
you need to be able to ask questions the
first step in data science is asking
question what is the problem you're are
trying to solve if you ask the right
question only then you'll get the right
answer very often this is a very crucial
step where a lot of data science
projects fail because you're you may be
asking the wrong question and then
obviously when you get the answer that's
not the answer you're looking for so it
is very important that you ask the right
question needless to say then the second
part or the second trait is common sense
so you need to be creative you need to
come up with ways to use the data that
you have and try to solve the business
problem on hand in many cases you may
not have all the data that you need in
many cases the data may be incomplete so
that is where you need to come up with
ways what are the best ways to fill
these gaps wherever this is missing and
that's where Common Sense comes into
play last but not least after doing all
this analysis if you are unable to
communicate the results in the right way
the whole exercise will fail so
communication is a key trait for a data
scientist maybe technically you may be a
genius but then if you are unable to
communicate those results in a proper
way once again that will not help so
these are the three main traits
curiosity common sense and communication
skills in a way you can say these are
the three C's okay so what are the other
prerequisites the first one so machine
learning machine learning is the
backbone of data science data science
involves quite a bit of machine learning
in addition to the basic statistics that
we do so a data scientist needs to have
a good hang or need to be very good at
data science the second part is modeling
so modeling is also a part of machine
learning in a way um but you need to be
good at identifying what are the
algorithms that are most suitable to
solve a given problem what models can we
use and uh how do we train these models
and so on and so forth so that is the
second component then statistics
statistics is like the core Foundation
of data science so you need to
understand statistics and you need to
have a good hang of Statistics in order
to be a good data scientist and this
will also help in getting good results
programming is to some extent required
at least some program or the other would
be required as a part of executing a
data science project the most common
programming languages are Python and R
python especially is becoming a very
popular programming language in data
science because of its ease of learning
because of the multiple uh libraries
that it supports for performing data
science and uh machine learning and so
on so python is by far one of the most
popular languages in data science if
anyone of you is is wanting to learn a
new language that should be Python and
then of course you need to understand
databases how databases work and how to
handle dat databases how to get data out
of databases and so on so these are some
of the key components of data science
now coming to the tools and skills that
are used in data science these are some
of the skills from a language
perspective it is python or R and from a
skills perspective in addition to some
of the programming languages it would
help if you have a good knowledge or
good understanding of statistics and
what are the tools that are used in data
analysis SAS is one of the most popular
tools it's been there for very long time
and uh that's the reason it is very
popular and however this is compared to
most of the other tools it is a
preparatory software whereas Python and
R are mostly open source the other tools
are like Jupiter Jupiter notebooks you
have R Studio these are more development
environments and development tools so
Jupiter not books as a interactive
development environment uh similarly our
studio is for performing or writing our
code and Performing analytics and um
performing data analysis and machine
learning activities you can perform in
our studio it has a very nice UI and
initially R was not so popular primarily
because it did not have user interface
and R studio is a relatively new edition
and after the Advent of R Studio R
became became extremely popular and
there are other tools like matlb and of
course some people do with Excel as well
as far as data warehousing is concerned
some of the skills that are required are
ETL so in order to extract data and uh
transform load ETL stands for extract
transform load so you have data in the
databases like your Erp system or a CRM
system you need to extract that and then
do some Transformations and then load it
into your Warehouse so that all the data
from various sources looks uniform then
you need some SQL skills which is
basically querying the data writing SQL
queries Hadoop is another important
skill especially if you're handling
large amounts of data and also one of
the specialities of Hardo is it can be
used for handling unstructured data as
well so it can be used for large amounts
of structured and unstructured data then
spark is a excellent computing engine
for performing data analysis or machine
learning in a distributed mode so if you
have large amount of data the
combination of spark and Hadoop can be
extremely powerful so you store your
data in Hadoop hdfs and use spark as
your computation engine it works in a
distributed mode similar to Hado in like
a cluster so that those are excellent
skills for data warehousing and there
are some standard tools that are
available like Informatica data stage
talent and also AWS red shift if you
want to do some on the cloud I think AWS
red shift is again a good tool data
visualization tools for data
visualization some of the skills that
would be required are let's say R you R
provides some very good visualization
capabilities especially for for
developing during development and then
you have python libraries matte plot lib
and so on which provides very powerful
visualization capabilities and that is
from skills perspective whereas tools
that can be used are Tableau is a very
very popular visualization tool again
that's a proprietory tool so it's a
little expensive maybe but excellent
capabilities from a visualization
perspective then there are tools like
cognos which is an IBM product which
provides very good visualization
capabilities as well and then coming to
the machine learning part of it the
skills required there are python which
is more for programming part and then
you will need some mathematical skills
like algebra linear algebra especially
and then statistics and maybe little bit
of calculus and so on and the tools that
are used for machine learning are spark
MLB and Apachi Maho and on cloud if you
want to do something you can use
Microsoft as your ml Studio as well so
these are by no means an exhaustive list
there are actually many many tools and
problem probably a few more skills Also
may be there but this is this gives a
quick overview like a summarizing of
summarization of the tools and skills
now moving on to the life of a data
scientist what does a data scientist do
during the course of his work so let's
see so typically a data scientist is
given a problem a business problem that
he needs to solve and in order to do
that if you remember from the previous
slide he basically asks the question as
to what is the problem that he needs to
solve so that is the first thing he has
got the problem then the next thing is
to gather the data that is required to
solve this problem so he goes about
looking for data from anywhere it could
be the Enterprise very often the data is
not provided in the nice format that he
would like to have it or we would like
to have it so first step is to get
whatever data that is possible what is
known as raw data in whatever format so
it could be Enterprise data it could be
there is a probably a required to go and
get some public data in some cases so
all that raw data is collected and then
that is processed and analyzed and in
prepared into a format in which it can
be used and then it is fed into the
analytic system be it a machine learning
algorithm or a statistical model and we
get the output and then he puts these
output in a proper format for presenting
it to the stakeholders and communicate
those insights or the results to the
stakeholder so this is a very high level
view of like a a day in the life of a
data scientist so Gathering data raw
data performing some quick analysis on
that and maybe processing or
manipulating this data to bring it into
a certain good format so that it can be
used for the analysis feeding this into
that analysis system that has been
designed be it mathematical models uh
machine learning models and then get the
results the insights and then present it
in a nice way so that the stakeholders
can understand how about machine
learning algorithms so let's see what
are the various machine learning
algorithms that would be required for a
data scientist so these are a few of the
algorithms again this not an exhaustive
list we have regression is one of the
supervised learning models or techniques
so in case of regression you try to
let's say come up with a continuous
number so the difference between
regression and let's say a
classification is that in case of
classification those are discrete values
whereas here we are talking about
regression where you let's say you are
trying to predict the temperature which
is a continuous value or the share price
which is a continuous value so that is
regression so you need to know what is
regression how to perform regression and
we we need to understand clustering so
clustering is one of the unsupervised
learning techniques in this case there
is no label data that is available and
you get some data and then you want to
put this into some shape so that you can
analyze it and you try to make sense out
of it let's say you have one example is
you have a list of cricketers and they
have not being marked as Bowlers and
batsmen or all-rounders or whatever
right so you just have their names and
maybe how many runs they scored how many
wickets they have taken and so on but
there is no readily available
information saying that okay this person
is a batsman this person is a bowler and
so on so I'm talking about Cricket
hopefully most of you are familiar with
the game of cricket so how do we find
out so then we put this into a
clustering mechanism and then the system
will say that okay these are the people
who are all who have all scored good
amount of runs so they belong to one
cluster these are all the people who
have taken good amount of wickets so
they belong to one cluster and maybe
here are some people who have taken good
amount of wickets and they have made
good amount of runs so they may be
belonging to one group and then we take
a look at it and then we label them as
okay people who have all together and
those who have you know scored many runs
they are we label them as batsmen people
who have taken a lot of wickets we label
them as Bowlers and people who have
taken good amount of wickets and also
made some good runs we label them as
all-rounders but the system will just
say okay this is cluster one cluster two
cluster three the names we give the
human beings have to give the names now
decision tree is used for what is known
as classification primarily it can also
be used for regression but by and large
it is used for classification and here
again it's a very logical way in which
the algorithm goes about about
classifying the various inputs one of
the biggest advantages of decision tree
is that it's very easy to understand and
it's very easy to explain why a certain
object has been classified in a certain
way compared to maybe some of the other
mechanisms like say support Vector
machines or logistic regression and so
on so that's the advantage of dis Tre
but that is also very popular algorithm
then we have support Vector machines
primarily for classification purpose and
and uh then we have KN base this is
again a statistical probability based
classification method so these are a few
algorithms there are a few more that are
not listed here but there are some more
algorithms as well and by the way there
are more detailed or there are detailed
videos about each of these algorithms
available you can check in the playlist
so now let's talk about the life cycle
of a data science project
okay the first step is the concept study
in this step it involves understanding
the business problem asking questions
get a good understanding of the business
model meet up with all the stakeholders
understand what kind of data is
available and all that is a part of the
first step so here are a few examples we
want to see what are the various
specifications and then what is the end
goal what is the budget is there an
example of the this kind of a problem
that has been maybe solved earlier so
all this is a part of the concept study
and another example could be a very
specific one to predict the price of a
1.35 karat diamond and there may be
relevant information inputs that are
available and we want to predict the
price the next step in this process is
data preparation data Gathering and data
preparation also known as data monging
or sometimes it is also also known as
data manipulation so what happens here
is the raw data that is available may
not be usable in its current format for
various reasons so that is why in this
step a data scientist would explore the
data he will take a look at some sample
data maybe pick there are millions of
Records pick a few thousand records and
see how the data is looking are there
any gaps is the structure appropriate to
be fed into the system are there some
columns which are probably not adding
value may not be required for the
analysis very often these are like names
of the customers they will probably not
add any value or much value from an
analysis perspective the structure of
the data Maybe the data is coming from
multiple data sources and the structures
may not be matching what are the other
problems there may be gaps in the data
so the data all the columns all the
cells are not filled if you're talking
about structured data there are several
blank blank records or blank columns so
if you use that data directly you'll get
errors or you'll get inaccurate results
so how do you either get rid of the data
or how do you fill this gaps with
something meaningful so all that is a
part of data monging or data
manipulation so these are some
additional sub topics within that so
data integration is one of them if there
are any conflicts in the data may be
data may be redundant yeah data res
redundancy is another issue there may be
you have let's say data coming from two
different systems and both of them have
customer table for example customer
information so when you merge them there
is a duplication issue so how do we
resolve that so that is one data
transformation as I said there will be
situations where data is coming from
multiple sources and then when we merge
them together they may not be matching
so we need to do some transformations to
make sure everything is similar we may
have to do some data reduction if the
data size is too big you may have to
come up with ways to reduce it
meaningfully without losing information
then data cleaning so there will be
either wrong values or you null values
or there are missing values so how do
you handle all of that a few examples of
very specific stuff so there are missing
values how do you handle missing values
or null values here in this particular
slide we are seeing three types of
issues one is missing value then you
have null value you see the difference
between the two right so in the missing
value there is nothing blank null value
it says null now the system cannot
handle if there are null values
similarly there is improper data so it's
supposed to be numeric value but there
is a string or a non-numeric value so
how do we clean and prepare the data so
that our system can work flawlessly so
there are multiple ways and and there is
no one common way of of doing this it
can vary from Project to project it can
vary from what exactly is the problem
you're trying to solve it can vary from
data scientist to data scientist
organization to organization so these
are like some standard practices people
come up with and and of course there
will be a lot of trial and error
somebody would have tried out something
and it worked and it'll continue to use
that mechanism so that's how we need to
take care of data cleaning now what are
the various ways of doing you know if if
values are missing How do you take care
of that now if the data is too large and
um only a few records have some missing
values then it is okay to just get rid
of those entire rows for example so if
you have a million records and out of
which 100 records don't have full data
so there are some missing values in
about 100 record so it's absolutely fine
because it's a small percentage of the
data so you can get rid of the entire
records which have missing values but
that's not a very common situation very
often you will have multiple or at least
you know large number of data set for
example out of million records you may
have 50,000 records which are like
having missing values now that's a
significant amount you cannot get rid of
all those records your analysis will be
inaccurate so how do you handle such
situation so there are again multiple
ways of doing it one is you can probably
if a particular values are missing in a
particular column you can probably take
the mean value for that particular
column and fill all the missing values
with the mean value so that first of all
you don't get errors because of missing
values and second you don't get results
that are way off because these values
are completely different from what is
there so that is one way then a few
other could be either taking the median
value or depending on what kind of data
we are talking about so something
meaningful we will have put in there if
we are doing some machine learning
activity then obviously as a part of
data preparation you need to split the
data into training and test data set the
reason being if you try to test with a
data set which the system has already
seen as a part of training then it will
tend to give reasonably accurate results
because it has already seen that data
and that is not a good measure of the
accuracy of the system so typically you
take the entire data set the input data
set and split it into two parts and
again the ratio can vary from person to
person individual preferences some
people like to split it into 50/50 some
people like it as
6333 and 33.3 is is basically 2/3 and
1/3 and some people do it as 80/20 804
training and 20 for testing so you split
the data perform the training with the
80% and then use the remaining 20% for
testing all right so that is one more
data preparation activity that needs to
be done before you start analyzing or
applying the data or putting the data
through the
model staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here